[Musique]
le monde selon ma mobylette en pologne
je suis ici à szczecin près de la
frontière allemande pour un périple le
long de la mer baltique qui devrait
m'emmener jusqu'à la frontière russe est
à peu près 800 km alors normalement
c'est le monde selon des mobylettes mais
je crois que cette fois ci ça avec le
monde se scooter parce que
malheureusement on peut pas trouver
nogrette d'occasion ici donc je vais
devoir me rabattre sur ce qu'on trouve
ici en deux roues 50 centimètres cube
c'est un scooter neuf et je pense que ça
devrait faire la faire quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plaques sont efficaces voilà longin
ça marche pas mal à mon petit scooter 50
centimètres cubes c'est l'équivalent
d'une mobylette
donc je suis et c'est une ville
construite selon un modèle haussmannien
paraît-il
mais il ya du rond point il ya des
tramways est partout il faut faire
vraiment attention
alors ça vaut rien les panneaux sur
lesquels je me base rap est facile dans
ce que ça je reconnais mais alors après
swing uci violons ça peut être facile
une petite ville qui a eu la
particularité d'être envahi
successivement par les prussiens les
allemands les danois et les suédois et
elle n'est redevenue polonaise qu'après
la seconde guerre mondiale
beaucoup de gens nous disent en fait que
c'est à une vraie ville polonaise est
pas rentrer dans cette polémique
c'est le quartier des garages ici s'y
installer ma plaque d'immatriculation
watts date machmouchi me dit c'est pas
possible que ça se disent comme ça avant
je tente jean d'aubry tiennent des blogs
la plaque
c'est possible
ils écouteront bien je vous dois un
thème
comment ça non
[Musique]
super merci beaucoup
bon ben voila je suis en règle
mon voyage commence bien
[Musique]
je croise les doigts
parce que j'ai quand même 800 kilomètres
à faire
j'ai quitté
setting j'ai quitté aussi n'était pas ce
que
pourtant quand je suis arrivé il faisait
chaud et maintenant il commence à faire
froid g
km après rapporteur
arrivé dans un petit village médiéval
[Musique]
on
ce
que
c'était bon
bon sympathique
faisons honneur à la fierté polonaise
dans un endroit stratégique
distillerie de vodka polonaise
[Musique]
cent mille litres de vodka if only vodka
alors de quoi est faite la vodka
traditionnel
la vodka traditionnel est conçu à base
de graines toutes sortes de graines et
surtout à base de pommes de terre
ici vous pouvez remarquer que nous avons
différents volumes de tonneaux des
petits des grands et l'un d'entre eux
celui ci
c'est un tonneau dont le liquide date de
l'alcool de base un ballon et blanc mais
après 60 années il devient sombre barbe
noire c'est le résultat de l'action
chimique entre l'alcool et le bois
de woods c'est très froid et humide ici
pourquoi nous avons ici une humilité et
une température constante mais cela
n'empêche pas en moyenne une évaporation
3% à taux nul appelons ici la part des
anges
la part des anges ouais c'est ça
maintenant je vais vous montrer le
niveau suivant en 207 à 20 mètres sous
terre
l'odeur est incroyable vraiment
c'est un peu effrayant non
vous pourrez en tourner un film
d'horreur oui c'est ça un film d'horreur
vous avez suffisamment de votre cas ici
pour enivrer toute la pologne
une semaine juste une semaine pour les
40 millions de personnes de ce pays oui
je pense que vous devez goûter notre
vote compte 25 ans d'âge
je ne devrais pas parce que je suis en
mobylette donc normalement je devrais
pas mais je vais juste la sentir
il
e
oui où
[Musique]
drôle rediscuter entre les vieux
remparts de la ville et les barres hlm
peut-être pas du tout des barres hlm
d'ailleurs
ok on mérite d'être un peu coloré au
moins
[Musique]
j'ai fait un petit tour dans la ville
mais quand même ce qu'il ya de plus
majestueux c'est de loin à cette église
qui est vraiment impressionnante et je
vais aller rencontrer le prêtre
de la paroisse pour lui poser quelques
questions sur la place de l'église en
pologne
[Musique]
bouh
piotr
pierre de father and father pierre mondy
mon père en français mon père
françois transformer rockets
enchanté
super
[Musique]
je
ça fait du bien à ce que
est ce que c'est une région difficile
les gens qui vivent ici j'ai senti
plutôt riche ou pauvre
on peut dire que la région est plutôt
pauvre
il y avait ici ce qu'on appelle en
pologne les pgr de grande coopérative
d'état
aujourd'hui c'est fini ça il n'y a plus
rien les gens ont dû partir ailleurs
chercher du travail
et beaucoup sont partis en angleterre en
allemagne en france en norvège
les femmes et les enfants sont restés
tandis que les hommes travaillent à
l'étranger est ce que les jeunes vont
toujours autant à l'église parce qu'on
sait que pour c'est un problème en
france pour les pour l'église catholique
c'est que les jeunes vont moins à
l'église est ce que ici c'est la même
chose ou mais la ferveur est toujours la
même ici
on constate que les jeunes surtout ceux
qui partent à l'étranger sont de moins
en moins lié à l'église
de manière générale les jeunes qui
travaillent en europe occidentale fut
peu appelée gliese ça se remarque de
plus en plus alors nous ici à notre
niveau au continue à prêcher la bonne
parole
comme l'a dit jean paul ii il faut un
nouvel esprit une nouvelle
évangélisation pour l'église
merci ma soeur
dit oh
mon dieu
ok
j'aime pas bien à savoir la
signification de pologne mais je pense
que ça veut dire plus
je plaisante voilà la direction qu'aux
obsèques
station thermale sur la côte je vais
peut-être en profiter pour faire une
petite thalasso
un scooter un peu plus puissant des
premiers scooters c'est un des premiers
rounds je vois sur la route en fait
ah ben voilà mon pote
et
bonjour
oh
jolie moto vous avez tout à l'heure
moi aussi je vous ai vu
trois sur un scooter scooter
vous aussi vous le premier que je croise
d'où je viens d'allemagne de hambourg
est bien équipé on n'a pas de chance
avec le temps non non mais c'est quoi
comme cylindrée c'est un 2,50 à l'âge de
5 ans
cela fait 5 fois la mienne à 12 200
utilise la même technique que j'utilise
un sac poubelle mais je le mets à
l'intérieur à l'intérieur oui c'est à
l'intérieur bah oui moi c'est à
l'extérieur
c'est quand même plus élégant bon
jusqu'à présent c'est quoi votre
impression sur la pologne
alors ça ressemble un peu haché moi
il n'y a pas une grande densité
d'habitants il y a de l'espace comme en
allemagne
c'est plus
vos gardes
deutsch tous deux vivent en dessous
allez hop hop là on y va
super et on
le laisse partir du morgen parce que tu
n'as aucune raison à ma vitesse
ok ça lui
c'est toujours déchirant
de quitter à un ami convient de se faire
comme ça
à peine j'avais rencontré un camelot
bon allez on va
avant cela est fait
[Musique]
allez ce soir au camping
car et technique
peut-être comme ça
peut-être comme ça voilà une tente
je sais pas si c'est le temps le plus
propice pour faire des rencontres ce
soir
pour aller faire chier pour aujourd'hui
j'ai eu ma dose
[Musique]
j'aime marcher
corps
et me voilà
dans la campagne polonaise
la route est belle
fort sympathique qui devrait un peu
des dégâts
bon allez
[Musique]
pas dire ce soit un spot de surf
c'est étonnant parce qu'en fait il est 9
heures du matin il ya déjà plein de
monde dehors
je pense que dans quelques années toute
la ville va être foutu parce que vu les
complexes qui s'apprête à construire
ça va être comme la costa brava dans
quelques années ben c'est pas mal en
famille mais quand tu es tout seul là
c'est pas un
jeu n'est pas très fin non
excusez là une kawa un café kawa
alouettes je voudrais les ans les bisons
de bourdes
bison
élections by the way bizarre zoom zoom
par la
c1 km
2 km double à abidjan j'ouvre la
doublait
bon en fait je suis dans un puits dans
un zoo quoi même pour se gratter le dos
on aura mis des les brosses tenus par
les barres de fer on n'est vraiment pas
dans ce que j'imagine et qui était
un parc naturel avec des troupeaux de
bisons
en liberté dans les plaines
bon et ben en fait le truc c'est qu'il
ya plus de touristes ici qu'il ya de
bison alors que moi j'imagine est un peu
les inverse et il ya quatre peaux de
bison et puis une quinzaine de touristes
rien un petit peu de déception pour mon
côté aventure
maintenant je vais aller voir les cool
je suis qu'au début de mon voyage et
tout ça peut encore changer
[Musique]
police où ça doit être un
restaurant de routiers qui vit ici les
chauffeurs routiers
dacca
a bien assez la spécialité spécialités
du chef ok super merci gaby
cheffe gabi way
le festin one
thing couillet super
ans le truc alors ça c'est étonnant qu
est-ce que j'ai abordé champignons comme
toujours
super ok
et
bien c'est un pépin mais un petit snack
bord de route aux états unis il ya les
flics rien fait que vient de se garer
devant les camions qui viennent qui
m'est offerte à tous c'est assez drôle
je veux lui même dans l'autre sens parce
que la serveuse une serveuse est
vraiment magnifique
[Musique]
allez salut
les gars vie tout le monde vient chez
toi pourquoi
tout le monde la police mais routier
pourquoi enfin la bonne bouffe
alors ces riches
j'adore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais les grands classiques le petit chat
le cheval sauvage
[Musique]
g
est-ce que excusez moi
ouais je parle anglais super salut
comment ça va alors comment ça se passe
on fait de notre mieux vous faites de
votre mieux ok c'est difficile de
trouver un boulot j'étais ici pour un
étudiant en pologne
ça dépend parce que la plupart des gens
qui veulent trouver un boulot parce
qu'ils aiment leur job mais pour avoir
un peu d'argent ils vont en angleterre
ou bien ils vont en allemagne en france
ici avant ça j'ai fait la même chose
qu'eux
qui sont les gens ici c'est
principalement des polonais
il y à des polonais bien sûr parce que
nous sommes sur la côte polonaise mais
il ya aussi beaucoup d'allemands qui
viennent ici
c'est un fait historique parce qu'ils
ont vécu ici
les allemands vivaient ici
c'était leur patrie
maintenant il va le voir ce qu'ils ont
perdu dans passé ils veulent visiter cet
endroit le montrer à leurs enfants à
leurs familles les allemands à le voir
ce qu'ils ont perdu il est polonais font
la même chose
oui mais les polonais avaient aussi
perdu ce territoire c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont heureux d'être là parce que
maintenant c'est définitivement chez eux
[Musique]
oui mais on a l'habitude comme tu peux
voir si c'est une jeunesse heureuse les
jeunes ne peuvent pas se souvenir de ça
ils l'ont appris à l'école eux ils sont
là uniquement pour le plaisir
tu as un beau métier regard cette fille
cas les actions qu'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant
il n'y a pas de héros ici c'est pas une
série télé
c'est pas comme alerte à malibu non
vraiment pas aucun nous aide à l'ue la
seule on ferme une équipe
merci beaucoup
bon voyage
eh les gars surveillez bien les filles
et n'ont perdu aucune
[Musique]
tous égaux les filles c'est bibi qui
arrive
ipa
sent déjà une autre atmosphère ici en
planche à voile
[Musique]
je sais quoi débranché
californienne star
[Musique]
je vais aller voir un peu comment se
déhanche la jeunesse de cracovie et
varsovie
stups en anglais
il ya beaucoup de gens de cracovie et de
varsovie pourquoi tous les gens viennent
ici
parce qu'on adore cette adresse je suis
françois
joly
[Musique]
well as presque oui en quelque sorte
c'est vrai c'est le seul lieu en pologne
où tu as la mère des deux côtés
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'intéressant
[Musique]
c'est la libye si tu sur le vif sur la
tête ou
fouet
ok
tu as
vu
[Musique]
je pense que tu peux trouver ici toutes
les classes sociales de la société
polonaise avoir à l'intérieur
c'est ça le phénomène d'être branché tu
doit appartenir à un groupe et tu te
sens appartenir à ce trou
je viens de france de france est ce que
les jeunes polonais voit le futur de
façon positive
bien sûr oui
je pense que ça ira de mieux en mieux
ravi de rencontrer qu'elle changeait
êtes ensemble depuis longtemps
depuis 6 ans 6 ans tu as juste le droit
de regarder
[Musique]
je pleure de fatigue
collègues
[Musique]
je
peu
oh
ils sont là les prix soleil
au secours
bon bah voilà
encore une fois tout ce que je ne veux
pas alors je m'attendais j'avais vu sur
un guide mais faut que j'arrête de lire
les guides
que j'arrivais dans une station thermale
j'imaginais un truc un peu à l'ancienne
avec son phare je vous pensais arriver
un endroit perdu face à la mer avec un
vieux phare je vais pas rester ici parce
que c'est tout ce que j'aime pas c'est à
dire les bateaux en plastique pour
touristes un phare à ce sujet par 15000
aux touristes ça sent la frite jarrett
j'arrête pas beaucoup liège mais
j'arrête de d'aller dans les villes qui
sont indiqués sur les guides et
je prends les directions uniquement de
bled paumé
[Musique]
baboo
oh
[Musique]
ouah
les couleurs incroyables
splendide
straw
c'est roman
voilà ça ça ressemble à ce que je veux
ça me passe quelque chose et je vais
essayer d'aller faire un tour au
chantier naval en face
chamakh sommet soit chamakh chamakh
chamakh hockey françois thiam est qu il
ya des bosses il est le boss ici oui je
fais mais van persie aurait tout ce que
je fais
beau père vous regarde faire oui mais je
suis le boss ici mais vous ne
construisez pas de bateau vous ne faites
que les réparer oui c'est ça on ne fait
que les réparer parce que dans la région
on n'a pas beaucoup d'argent pour les
gros chantiers et ici on ne fabrique pas
de nouveaux bateaux de pêche
fishbone ont fait le tour
alors ces bateaux où vont-ils pêché dans
la mer baltique et pourquoi même temps
ils partent en mer trois mois
non une semaine c'est assez pour remplir
avant tout
oui vraiment celui ci par exemple
contient 70 tonnes de poissons
fif 70 tonnes de poissons
celui là par exemple 40 tonnes quel
genre de travail vous faites sur ces
bateaux celui là par exemple du décapage
ça vous faites aux sables
on nettoie on fait un peu de tout on les
nettoie les salons une étoile eau douce
parce que vous savez le sel de la mer
baltique sais c'est pas bon pour les
bateaux
il ya toujours une odeur sur les bateaux
de pêche
celui-là
est dit donc là il va falloir réparer
tout ça ça pour combien de temps pour
être abîmée comme ça dix ans -
a plus
normalement on savait ici les armateurs
ils sont un peu ah oui les armateurs
ils veulent dépenser le moins possible
vous savez maintenant sur la côte
baltique dans le veau est devenu l'un
des plus grands ports
[Musique]
vous êtes bien organisé
c'est vachement intéressant ce qui m'a
expliqué c'est qu'en fait il faut
sablage à partir de particules de métal
qui rachète aux fonderies donc c'est la
poussière de métal dont ils se servent
pour faire le sablage sur les bateaux et
ont retiré la vieille peinture ensuite
ils ramassent ça et ils le rendent à ces
sociétés qui leur vendent pour faire des
remblais des autoroutes
c'est le rôle d'un récup
c'est des bons ici
si un jour j'ai un bateau je sais où je
la mènerai pour le faire réparer
féret en pologne
c'est un petit pas pour l'homme
a il pleut il ya souvent la pluie mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays pleut il
ya du soleil
allez on devrait se montrer la
merci beaucoup
j'adore l'odeur ici
il y a
ah non
je fonce à l'abri
[Musique]
oui
m
non
[Musique]
nova
non
on aura série météorologiques
maintenant c'est le bon
ce matin il fait très beau
alors je me tape un vent incroyable
et c'est vrai que le scout sous la pluie
c'est pas mal parce que ça me protège
mais alors ça prend vraiment le vent
faut faire gaffe
nous retrouvons encore certaines
portions d'autoroute
en fait en pologne a eu un phénomène
assez particulier la pologne était le
pays d'europe avant la guerre où il y
avait le plus de manoirs et châteaux et
pendant l'ère communiste la plupart ont
été réquisitionnés pour m soit des
familles logées des familles ou faire
des coopératives agricoles
ensuite après la chute du communisme la
plupart soit ont été privatisées pour
faire des hôtels et puis dans certains
de ses manoirs les familles sont restées
forcément sans argent pour les restaurer
et
ça a été le cas de celui ci
que je viens visiter aujourd'hui
c'est dommage
voilà toute une famille
ouais
vous habiter ici oui c'est abandonner
oui complètement les gens d'ici ont été
déplacées
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus personne il y
avait des familles qui habitaient dans
le palais pendant un moment c'est ça
oui il y avait beaucoup de monde car
tous travailler ici c'était un pgr issil
comme on dit en polonais coopérative
agricole et les gens travaillaient là
les deux ailes du château était occupée
malheureusement après tout ça était allé
aux mains d'investisseurs privés et la
commune a dû faire évacuer les lieux
mais personne ne s'en occupe lui
aujourd'hui
c'est un palais qui avait été
réquisitionné c'est ça à l'époque de
l'ère communiste je pense que c'était ça
le système
temps du communisme c'est devenu une
propriété de l'état repasse faut bien au
maine il y avait ces appartements
un club
tas de choses
c'était vivant ici
appartenait à l'état pur je n'ai plus
tard lorsque le communisme est tombé
c'était censé revenir à des m'a pris
j'ai
regardé ça s'est pas très bien passé
ceux qui avaient été expropriés est ce
que c'est ce qu'ils ont récupérés ou
alors c'est complètement différent le
propriétaire est différent donc ce sont
des investisseurs privés qui voulait
surtout avoir accès aux prêts il y en a
pleins tout autour grâce aux aides de
l'union européenne ils travaillent les
terres les labours et ils ont en plus dû
récupérer ce château pour avoir ses
terres c'était la contrepartie elles
sont pas d'ici
[Musique]
même si c'est super dangereux de venir
ici
j'ai quand même réussi à trouver une
entrée ce sont des pièces en enfilade
faire vraiment attention parce que le
les plafonds sont en train de vraiment
de littéralement s'écouler on peut
toujours imaginer
réhabiliter et refaire un château un
panneau comme celui là
effectivement ça demande des moyens
colossaux offres
ont fait le tour
assez incroyable il ya des synonymes est
partout partout partout partout
[Musique]
et
à peu près 50% de ses palais qui sont
rachetés pour en faire des hôtels c'est
quand même le seul moyen de pouvoir les
garder en bon état et sinon ce sont des
businessmen polonais qui rachète ses
palais à des sociétés d'état qui sont
bien contents de pouvoir les revendre
parce que ça fait très cher de les
entretenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut les gars allez ciao ciao
et merci pour tout
[Musique]
j'ai de la chance parce que le gardien a
bien voulu me laisser monter à 40 mètres
de hauteur sur le phare de la presqu'île
de hel et tout au bout de la presqu'île
et
de l'autre côté il ya le continent avec
de la pluie alors il ya un petit port de
pêche ici j'ai vu des petits bateaux je
vais aller faire un tour sur le port et
essayer de trouver un marin qui veut
bien emmener de l'autre côté
bon bah voilà ça c'est le ferry que je
vais pas prendre
ça c'est le petit bateau qui va
m'emmener
il a accepté qu'on mette le scooter dans
son bateau on va essayer
super
ok
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez été pêcheur toute
votre vie oui j'étais pêcheur toute ma
vie ça fait plus de 50 ans je pêche
mon père aussi été pêcheur il avait une
autre marque sans moteur
on sera là
je suis on
et vous aussi vous l'avez cuir à la rame
ouais ouais ouais
ils achètent sur un voilier aussi vous
savez avec une voile
et ce genre de barques j'ai tellement
bien construit que ça peut jamais coulé
en fait celle d'arc à la longueur d'une
vague cette mallette après
le risque c'est toujours que
les bateaux et peu long
des vagues c'est qu'il ya une cassure
alors que là il suit toujours
je le comprends
c'est bien
français
[Musique]
à
mua
vive la france vive un techo des gaules
john casey
l'emporter
et c'est reparti
la pluie
oui
le seul
[Musique]
autant sur le continent
je vais
il pas et ne plaît pas
[Musique]
on les tramways qui arrive là c'est
schoder
chaud chaud chaud
[Musique]
on peut pas venir en pologne sont
évoqués quand même les chantiers navals
de danse ou en 80 le
ont dirigé par lech walesa a commencé
c'est dans cet endroit que les que les
ouvriers ont fait la grève contre le
pouvoir parce qu'ils perdaient vous avez
petit pouvoir d'achat
alors on m'a laissé 30 minutes pour me
promener dans chantiers navals et
j'avoue que je suis assez impressionné
quand même
en fait c'est émouvant pour moi d'être
ici
c'est un des premiers faits
d'actualité et historique que j'ai suivi
quand j'étais adolescent comme tout le
monde et je m'attendais pas à ça mais en
fait ça me fait tout drôle de me
retrouver ici
vous êtes vous voyez ici au chantier
naval vous étiez là pendant les grèves
qui a eu dans les années 80 pour les
gens ici est ce que c'est important et
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que ça a
changé est ce que c'est une fierté
aujourd'hui les gens sont plutôt
désabusé déçu ce n'est plus le même
chantier naval perdre la vie si on
construisait 30 bateaux par an si ça
paie aujourd'hui j'avais bien vu il ne
se passe plus grand chose
avant les magasins étaient vides
aujourd'hui la boutique regorge de
produits mais avant il y avait du
travail et maintenant vous voyez bien ce
qui se passe
non seulement il y à la crise en pologne
mais nous en plus dans les chantiers on
est doublement touchés l'union
européenne a rendu un avis favorable à
notre encontre concernant les aides
d'état
mais ça ne sert pas à grand chose on ne
sait pas comment tout ça va finir ni
même où on sera dans deux mois
[Musique]
en trop encore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
bon alors c'est drôle parce que comme
les gens vont vous tournez dans le
village ils m'ont indiqué la maison du
maire alors le maire il est là
et quand il a vu que j'arrivais il a
commencé à faire un peu le ménage à
bouger deux trois trucs pour que ce soit
propre
voilà
salut françois jean do vrai monsieur le
maire jean dhobley
à la
alors je suis selmer ici sûrs d'eux
c'est vous le patron du village alors
oui je suis le maire si la campagne
locaux gnesa de banane c'est la campagne
c'est pas très organisés mais ces
sympathiques
ces bâtisses inri sympathique
la vie tranquille on est tranquille les
gens qui vivent ici ce sont des fermiers
il n'y a que des agriculteurs ici il ya
beaucoup de vaches laitières dans le
quelques paysans cultivent le blé pour
leur consommation personnelle pour
nourrir leurs bêtes
est ce que les jeunes trouvent
facilement du travail ici ou doivent-ils
partir en ville
il y à pas mal de jeunes agriculteurs
ici
ils ont hérité la terre de leurs parents
il est la boue les cultivent et
agrandissent leur ferme
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
d'autres jeunes sont partis à l'étranger
comme beaucoup de leurs compatriotes
parfois très loin
ceux qui ne peuvent pas vivre de leurs
terres sans vont soit dans d'autres
régions
soit dans d'autres villes soient à
l'étranger
surtout à l'étranger dire
je pense que c'est un peu le même
phénomène un peu partout en europe
[Musique]
le meilleur bond comment devient ton le
maire d'un village comme ça
les villageois se réunissent tous les
quatre ans qu'il ya des élections
municipales et c'est le village qui
déchire
et vous allez essayer d'être réélu vous
allez arrêter le boulot top job
non non non non non et non je ne veux
plus une fois
si on veut bien faire les choses en fait
il ne faut faire que ça c'est ce qu'on
pourrait être tout le temps sur son
ordinateur il ya tout gérer tout régler
c'est énormément de travail
ça dépend de ce qu'on aime aussi quand
on a rien sans rien si les machines et
c'est la vérité nous les maires on n'est
pas payé ça que cheikh l'internet
internet ou le téléphone téléphone où on
ne nous rembourse pas non
mais il ne s'agit pas que d'argent je ne
veux plus être maire une deuxième fois
un point c'est tout
ce sont les gens du village qui m'ont
élu est un peu par hasard
le
[Musique]
on
prend un petit
way
eh bien ça bien fort la lega
où aller huit albums j'ai toujours
enseigné
la langue bien je reviens
[Musique]
c'est c'est facile de faire de l'argent
quand on vit dans un bled comme ça la
campagne
commence assez facile
si tu achètes rien tu n'as rien
bon c'est vrai que quand tu habites à la
campagne tu as bien un veau un cochon du
lait des oeufs situe élève des poules ça
oui
c'est certainement plus facile de vivre
dans ces conditions à qu'être au chômage
envie non
comme on dit c'est plus facile à la
campagne mais tous les agriculteurs ne
sont pas aussi travailleur parfois ils
ont la flemme ils n'ont pas grand chose
à manger mais pour trouver de l'argent
pour la vodka ça il n'y a aucun problème
c'est vrai je connais ils n'ont pas
d'argent pour se nourrir mais ils on
trouve toujours pour de la voir
bon bah moi je
veux mais tu l'as
fait chaud ça pique nique players and
super
thé voire esthétique non
[Rires]
c'est bien toi
on est à cheval
[Musique]
salon
c'est vrai que même si je vais pas vite
en mobylette et ça fait pas beaucoup de
bruit
c'est bien sympa de finir ce voyage
comme ça tranquille avec monsieur le
maire tracté par un cheval sur ces
petites routes à quelques kilomètres de
la russie on est vraiment tranquille
tout bien
on respire
c'est simple ça sent bon super
[Rires]
je vais à fond là 60
c'est à ce moment que j'ai internet 60
et voilà
non
en la pologne
[Musique]
c'est tout à fait étonnant j'ai pris une
autoroute
qui s'arrête ici ça y est je suis au
bout de la pologne de l'autre côté là
bas c'est la russie c'est la fin de
l'union européenne c'est la fin de
l'europe ici il ya un panneau qui
l'indiquent est en fait ce qui est tout
à fait étonnant c'est que cette
autoroute a été construite c'est
l'ancien en autoroute qui allait de
berlin à konigsberg et cette autoroute
en fait ne continue pas de l'autre côté
les rues sont pas encore faits l'autre
tronçon donc je suis arrivé un poste
frontière fantôme il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de type en faction
n'y a pas de douaniers y à rien il ya
simplement cette douane prête à
fonctionner qui attend les russes
fassent leurs autoroutes
c'est la fin la pologne
et si je passe cette barrière je quitte
l'europe
et
j'ai fini ce voyage mais comme je vais
pas repartir avec ce scooter
j'ai décidé de le donner à ceux qui à
mon avis on a eu le plus besoin c'était
cette famille fort sympathique qui vit à
côté du
délabré avec toutes ces cigognes donc je
me dirais vers le palais ont ordonné en
petit scout qui a bien tenu la route
tiens tiens tiens tiens tu sais que là
alors les gamins
ça va ça va non
c'est cool génial
[Musique]
génie
j'avais peur qu'il soit pas là
[Musique]
ben voilà il ya tout le monde
alors
ok hague au bâton je vais rentrer en
france soir - tgv ces deux scouts je
pouvais vous donner ce scooter c'est
bien non
ils sont super contents ça c'est sûr
ça va être quelque chose ici entre tous
les gamins je sais pas à mon avis va
servir pendant longtemps
[Musique]
je crois que pour finir
reprendrait plus
[Musique]